- By now it's March.
Winter's over, the weather's
starting to warm up.
Starting to feel vestiges,
signs of heat again,
and Pete and I are about
to pass through a doorway.
We're about to step
across a threshold
into a section of the canyon
that is rumored by
those who know it,
and those who know it
are very small in number
to be, perhaps,
the most isolated
and the most pristine
section of the canyon of all.
The Western Grand Canyon.
A world of its own,
and we're gonna begin
moving through it.
(water gurgling)
(grunting)
- [Pete] Stay.
The last source
was dry as a bone.
Anything out there?
- [Kevin] Bone dry out here.
- [Pete] It looks like a
swimming pool from here.
Ooh.
- [Kevin] Not good.
- Bone dry.
If you don't know
if there's water,
makes you a little stressed
to say the least.
When we started this
walk across Grand Canyon
some 500 miles to
the east of here,
a friend told us we'd
learn the difference
between what we want
and what we need.
As Kevin and I marched
into Western Grand Canyon,
we'd felt like we passed
through a secret passageway
into what some describe
as the Gods' Gate,
a place very few visit.
It's day 45 of walking.
No precipitation in sight,
even though it's mid-February,
and we are back in full desert.
(rock clattering)
Did you step on that?
Western Grand Canyon is
incredibly remote and immense
and then some.
And water is extremely scarce.
That scarcity reminded us daily
that the park and all
the development projects
surrounding its landscape
share this major, often
overlooked obstacle,
limited water.
Finding water when you're
far from the river,
sometimes 3,000 feet
above it, isn't easy.
So we depended on very
thin, very unpredictable
potholes of rainwater.
- See how deep it is.
- [Kevin] It's pretty nice.
And we have two syringes
with us this time.
That's like a swimming pool.
- [Pete] Just
don't fall in there
'cause there's no bottom in
that thing that I can see.
That's got four liters in it.
They were the key
to our survival.
- [Kevin] The water challenge
is a day-by-day thing.
Every morning we
start the search anew.
- [Pete] Just constantly
amazed by the liquid silence
that seems to
blanket us down here.
(dramatic music)
- [Pete] Is there any water?
- [Kevin] No!
- [Pete] You alright?
- [Kevin] You have a
clean pair of underwear?
- [Pete] Now's not
the time right now
to be joking around.
- Did you hear that?
- [Pete] Are you okay?
- Yeah. Good.
- I thought you fell.
- [Kevin] No.
- [Pete] You scared
the hell out of me.
- Just the rocks.
(mumbles) challenging with
this pack.
Pack makes it a little harder.
- [Pete] After hiking
some 12 to 15 miles a day
for over a month,
and some days hiking over
20 miles to reach water,
let's just say it wore us down.
What's up with your feet?
- They really hurt.
- My body's falling apart.
- I feel like I'm
in a Swedish sauna.
- Nice, our 50th day,
on the trail of whatever.
It may have been the
brushiest, scratchiest,
longest day, wow.
At times--
- I feel like woo-woo.
- [Pete] Kevin
might've even become
a tad grouchy.
- Sublime, Obi-Wan Kenobi
style, jiu jitsu wilderness,
hoo-ha, I'm like
(bleep) that, (bleep) that.
This just blows.
- [Pete] Look where
we've come from.
- [Kevin] Yeah, look
where we've come from,
(bleep)ing nowhere!
(audience laughing)
- [Pete] Our encounters
with cactus didn't help.
I'll get em.
- [Kevin] I fell
into a barrel cactus,
and now I got all these weird
lumps on my arm. (grunts)
OK, let's put the camera away.
(audience groans)
Whoo, they hurt.
- [Pete] Oh, God.
- [Kevin] Grand Canyon
bites literally.
- Made my calf go numb.
Ooh!
I got ya, I got ya on the spot.
- [Kevin] I really don't like
this.
- [Pete] Physical
challenges aside,
careful,
we discovered a
solitude and stillness
that we've experienced
nowhere else.
As we approached the end
of the park and our walk
we discovered and heard
a different Grand Canyon.
(helicopter whirring)
A tourist boom has
followed the success
of the recent
Skywalk development
on the Hualapai reservation
on the southwest
corner of the park.
Over a decade ago,
the FAA granted
the approval to fly
and land helicopters
below the rim,
what is now called
Helicopter Alley,
located on the border
of the national park.
It is now one of the busiest
heliports in the world.
(helicopter whirring)
- This wave of
industrialized
high volume tourism
coming to the national park.
The acceleration of
this kind of activity
has been incredible.
- Economic enterprise
of these tribal nations
is important for them.
They basically starved
for a hundred years,
now they have something.
(deep rhythmic music)
- The helicopters are a mess.
There's just
constant air traffic,
and it affects the wildlife.
We're a hunting tribe.
- Propagate forward 15 years,
is there anything left here?
Have we really done
what we set out to do,
what Teddy Roosevelt
set out to do,
in letting mainly
the rest of the world
come fly over Grand
Canyon National Park
and negate the laws that we
created to protect these places.
- So this amazes me,
because this is
our national park.
And I think what amazes
me most about this
is that 10 years ago
this didn't exist.
Now this, I want to be clear,
this is something I
worked very hard on,
this is a photographic merge.
I went out there,
I spent all day,
this was July 9th,
I took a picture of
every single helicopter
that flew through my frame.
In an eight-hour period,
I counted 363 helicopters,
and then all those that
flew through my frame,
some flew above the frame,
some flew illegally
into the park air space,
but I stitched them together
just to show what the impact is
of a day's worth of
traffic inside Grand Canyon
in a place that didn't exist.
And they're landing on
the Hualapai reservation,
and the Hualapai deserve to
have viability, of course,
but it's raising
the question on,
we just want to raise
the questions on
how do we find that balance
between what's too
much and not enough.
I was curious about
how this works,
what's the experience like,
I actually went to Las Vegas,
the proximity to Las Vegas
is driving a lot of this,
it's a half-hour flight.
They'll pick you up in
your hotel with a limo,
you'll do a 10-minute
limo ride to the airport,
you do a 22-minute ride
out to the Grand Canyon,
you come have a small
bottle of champagne
and a yogurt
and by the time,
when I was there,
it was a crowded day,
there were 16 helicopters
parked around me.
When I was trying
to have my yogurt,
four helicopters
flew over my head
and blew me with yogurt.
(audience laughing)
Then we were raced back
into the helicopter,
28-minute flight back,
limo back to the hotel,
and I was ready to have brunch
and check my Grand Canyon
box that I had done it
by 11:30 in the morning.
Now I understand access,
I understand some people
don't live near Grand Canyon,
and I understand that
nobody's gonna be dumb enough
to do a walk like
Kevin and I did.
But it is remarkable
to me to think
how we look at wilderness,
and we're trying to
raise the question,
how do we appreciate
these places,
and this may not be
the way to appreciate
its great asset like
silence and humility.
- Yeah, and it's hard,
really, to sort of
express in words.
The violence of the contrast
between the noise that's
generated by these machines
and the tranquility of
the landscape itself,
as you move though this
section of the park.
And I just want to
take a moment to say
as a writer,
what a privilege it is to
work with a photographer
who's capable of
capturing an image
like the one that just
preceded this one.
I think it's such
an amazing thing
to somehow be able to layer
information so densely
that you can communicate
it in a single instant
what might take me pages
upon pages to relay.
Now that contrast is really
harsh as you move across
the westernmost section
of the Grand Canyon.
And the thing about the
canyon, too, is that
you'd think that the
further out you get
and the closer to
the end you get,
that it might begin to
kinda let you down easily,
but that's definitely
not the case.
I never knew that
it was possible
for cactuses to grow
in the form of forests,
but they do.
(audience chuckling)
It's very difficult
and unpleasant
to move through
this sort of thing.
It's also challenging
out there in the west
to realize how much up and down
descending and ascending
is demanded of you,
tens of thousands of
feet each and every day.
You need to climb
and then descend
in order to keep
moving laterally
downstream, down canyon.
Then you need, too, to perform
a level of rock climbing
that I'm really not capable of,
technical moves
that lie far beyond
my ability and exist
outside of my comfort zone,
and then for whatever
reason, we also found that
we're seeing more
and more animals
on this westernmost section
of the Grand Canyon.
Unpleasant animals,
animals that I was not
super into, I have to say.
(audience laughing)
- Sorry.
Yeah, there are some critters
that like to bite down there.
But we generally
leave them alone.
Another interesting thing for me
when we got to this part
of the western canyon,
a lot of people, if you've
been down the Grand Canyon
by a boat,
a lot of the rafting trip
ends in this part of the canyon.
We're at about mile 250
on the river,
most ship you out either
on a night rift
or you hike out or you
can take a helicopter out.
But these sections
here were daunting,
we're climbing 3,000
feet to the river
to try to document things,
we're coming 3,000 feet up,
but it amazed me is that
despite the challenges
and the rigor of this,
is that we're coming up
these ancient Anasazi routes.
This was a route that
I would've never have
guessed we could get out
and get back up onto
the sanup level,
3,000 feet above the river,
but when when we
approached this little tiny
break in the rock at the top,
which I'm standing on,
you come around the corner
and you see a tiny pictograph,
and then you come
a little closer,
and you see a cedar
log that has been there
with no other logs, no other
trees anywhere in sight,
it's been there for
probably 800 years.
And you can see where it had
been chipped a little bit,
where they had notched
it into this spot
so they could climb up.
It's now since fallen
and we have to perform
a climbing move,
but it's remarkable.
And then as we move up these
ancient Anasazi routes,
we've conditioned
ourselves a little bit,
where we're moving now at night.
We're realizing that
we can keep moving,
we can make more miles,
we have to make more
miles here because
the water sources are
further and further apart.
Sometimes when they
do show up, of course,
they're deeper
than we want them.
But we also realize it
has changed our bodies.
We've not only
psychologically changed
on some level, but
physically we've changed.
We've gotten more used
to carrying weight,
we've gotten more nimble,
we've gotten a
little more balanced.
And apparently I lost
my beer belly somewhere.
(audience laughing)
Part of this is due
to the diet we're on,
we're carrying roughly
2,000 calories a day
and we're probably
burning 5,000.
I lost 30 pounds on the trip.
- Yeah, it's no
overstatement to say that
the canyon is transforming
and reshaping our bodies.
It's also transforming
and reshaping our minds
and our sensibilities.
And I think it's fair
to say, too, that
I'm 51 years old, you're
four years younger than me.
- Something like that.
14 years younger.
(audience laughing)
I'm gonna move us up this slide,
'cause I get gross
looking at that.
(audience laughing)
- At this point,
we are probably in what we will
later look back
upon and recognize
as the shape of our lives.
And we're also seeing
signs that the canyon
is about to start letting us go.
Because it's out
here in the West
that the Grand
Canyon National Park
comes to an end.
It's a testament
to the remoteness
and just how pristine
this place actually is.
That when you get to
the far end of this,
the crown jewel of American's
national park system,
the only thing that
marks the border
are three metal stakes,
driven into the sage brush
in what feels like
the middle of nowhere.
- So that's our final step
in Grand Canyon National Park.
But of course, boundaries
weren't always drawn
by geography or watersheds.
So we still had 3,500
vertical feet to descend
through Pearce Canyon,
where the actual canyon itself
lets you out through
this gentle release
out into the desert.
And we come down and we
blow up our pack rafts,
which are these
two-pound little items
that are like paddling
a pool toy with a Q-Tip.
(audience laughing)
I probably could blow
Kevin and knock him over,
so it's a little bit tenuous,
but to be honest,
this was probably
the most luxurious
three miles left of the trip.
This was we're out of the park,
the walk is complete.
So just three weeks
ago in November,
we both emerged on Pearce Ferry
and one of us had
completed the walk.
I say one of us because
we decided to do
this walk as a team
and to do something unusual.
One of us is the 34th person
to ever walk through
Grand Canyon.
But we realized that this
isn't about walking a park,
and it's not about
being on a list.
So the other one of us
floated a hundred yards,
only know between us,
and left that section
undone because
the reality is, this
place is too big,
it's too grand, it's too vast,
it's too remarkable to know,
to conquer, to
understand with one line
even by foot through it.
It would take more
than a lifetime
to understand this place.
- It does take more
than a lifetime
to understand this place.
It is complex, it is enormous.
But that doesn't mean that
we can't apply ourselves
to the question,
what did it mean,
what did it teach us.
And when Pete and
I sat down together
and we grappled with that,
we realized that
there were four things
that the canyon did.
They're really
sort of four gifts
that the canyon gave us
in the form of insight.
And tonight, we're gonna
share those four with you.
The first of them has
to do with the fact that
this place is a
national treasure.
And its assets are normally
framed and described
and articulated in terms that
are fundamentally visual.
Think about it for a moment.
If you've been to the canyon
or if you've never
been to the canyon
but you're speaking about or
thinking about the canyon,
the vocabulary
that you reach for
has to do with the
color of the light,
the texture of the rock,
the lines of the canyon itself.
The odd and unexpected
thing that Pete and I discovered
that amounted to a
kind of epiphany,
was that we gradually
began to realize
at some point, some
indeterminable point between
Lees Ferry and the
Grand Wash Cliffs,
we realized that the greatest,
least appreciated and
most vulnerable treasure
that Grand Canyon
National Park contains
is not visual, it's auditory.
Because it is out there
that you are able to encounter
a level of silence
that you can find nowhere else.
Why is that precious and
why does that matter?
Among other reasons
because it stands
in such profound contrast
to everything that surrounds us
in the world beyond the rims.
A world that is governed
and defined by noise.
A world whose noise prevents us
from articulating and framing
and contemplating
things that we don't
have the time or the
attention span to appreciate.
And so that is one of
the greatest things
that the park has to offer,
and it's one of the
things that we feel
is most necessary to protect.
- The second lesson
we learned is that
whatever happens on the rim,
we often think that's
a separate world
from the canyon itself.
And the reality is,
no matter how you see
or enjoy the park,
if you come to the Skywalk,
this is in the western
side of the park
that now gets a
million visitors,
if you come to the South
Rim or the North Rim
or you're two hikers
that come and do it,
whatever happens on the rim
or whatever small impact
it may seem on the rim
is directly related to what
happens inside the park.
It is this remarkable rock maze
that is all interconnected.
This little spring here
flows out of the rock
3,000 feet downstream,
about 40 miles
from the South Rim.
And it just suddenly emerges.
But it's directly linked
to the water table
on the South Rim.
And biologists say that
the ecosystem that
survives here,
they say the ecosystems
in Grand Canyon
are some of the greatest
in all our national parks.
It survives in some
places nowhere else.
You find endangered
species of fish
and creatures that they
are just learning exist.
So it is entirely
connected, the rim,
to these small
secret worlds below.
- Incredibly complicated
and incredibly delicate,
interconnected matrix.
The third gift, the
third gift is something
that you encounter
at the moment when
you realize that your first
impression of this place
when you move into it and
you're unfamiliar with it,
the impression that it is empty,
that it is devoid
of human beings
is fundamentally wrong.
Because as you move
through this landscape,
as you move across
the arc of days
and weeks and months
and entire seasons,
as you spend an entire
year inside of this place,
you begin to realize
that it is a space that was
once filled with people,
people who existed inside of it
and called it home for
tens of thousands of years,
and the evidence
of their presence
is absolutely everywhere.
It exists on the ground,
you can see the tools
and the artifacts
that they left behind,
you could see places
that they lived,
the homes that
they dwelt inside,
and at very special and
very secret locations
that you are
privileged to encounter
only if you are
very, very lucky,
you may see on the rock itself,
imprinted on the rock itself
a vision that these people
created which suggests
something about how they
understood their position
in the universe itself.
- Their art, which you
can find in certain areas,
I want to give you
a little description
of how remarkable this piece is.
I can't tell you where it is,
I was given permission
to share it with you,
but this a
4,000-year-old painting
that's called a polychrome.
Basically has four colors on it,
there's quite a few
of them scattered
throughout Grand Canyon,
people aren't exactly sure of
who did it or how they did it.
And then there's the question of
where did they go,
where did all these people,
this vast population that
lived inside Grand Canyon.
And the truth is,
they haven't gone anywhere.
They're right here,
they're living all around
Grand Canyon National Park.
There's nine Native
American tribes
that live around Grand
Canyon National Park.
And they're active and
engaged in all sides of it.
They're active on all fronts
of the development pressures
that are happening.
Some are for it and
actively involved
in the economics of it,
some are opposed to it and
fighting for their lives
and trying to keep what
they consider sacred alive.
And it is very complex
and important to note that
what's happening now
is driving a lot of it,
it's pitting certain tribes
against other tribes,
this is where the tram would go,
this is where you would
have 10,000 people a day
coming down to a food emporium.
And it's as complex as the
geology of the canyon itself.
- Which brings us to the
fourth and final gift.
You think about
the Grand Canyon,
these sorts of things
are incredibly important,
the politics, the issues
that surround this place,
the fundamental questions
about environmentalism
and preservation
and conservation.
But ultimately,
you come up against
an idea that's very,
very different,
which is that,
and it's really not an idea
as much as a possibility,
it's the possibility
expressed in the notion
that what this place contains
that may be the most important
resides in an opportunity.
It's an opportunity that we have
when we move into
these landscapes.
And the opportunity has to do,
not with the land itself,
not with the threats
that may hang over,
the debates about
whether those things that
are being proposed
are right or wrong.
It's about the connections
that happen between people
when they come to
our national parks.
Ultimately, the
story of our parks
is the story of people,
it's the story of experiences
that we have in them,
it's the story of friendship.
It's also a story
about how friendship
matures and blossoms
into community
and how community
becomes family.
And when you try to
wrap your head around
all of those things,
the connectivity,
the idea that silence
may be the most important
treasure of all,
the notion that the
connections between
human beings may
express themselves
and come to matter more
than the land itself.
You find yourself coming
up against an idea
that the park is greater
than the sum of its parts.
And I think that's an idea that
Pete has really sort of
brought to the fore beautifully
in the final video that we'd
like to share with you tonight.
- [Pete] When we
started this walk,
we had no idea what
we'd gotten into
nor how hard this
undertaking would be.
Our 60-day, over
650-mile hiking immersion
was not about being on a list.
It was about understanding
a shared resource,
the crown jewel of our
national park system.
While it was a
journey to find a line
through one of the seven
natural wonders of the world
between the river and the rim,
it was also a quest to
understand what might change
or be lost in this
rock cathedral.
If we don't find a balance
between growing
development pressures,
resource extraction,
and the sublime beauty
that defines this
iconic landscape.
And how we decide to
use and experience
our last wild places
will dictate what the future
of this place looks like.
the story that we've spent
the last year of our lives
working on comes down
to a single question,
that question is this,
how do we view this space?
How do we view it as citizens,
how do we view it as Americans.
Do we view it as a
place that is sacrosanct
and holy and inviolable,
or do we view it as a theater
for our own amusement?
A place that titillates us,
provides us with
recreation and enjoyment.
And Pete and I are not proposing
that we have an answer to
that question to you tonight.
We're merely placing the
question in front of all of you
for your consideration,
but we will say one thing.
There's a lot of places
in the United States
that look like this.
Wanna know how many
of them there are?
- There are a lot of amusement
parks in this country.
And one thing we have
learned after sweating,
bleeding, crying, whining,
and crawling through
the Grand Canyon
is there's only one place
that looks like the seventh
natural wonder of the world.
So thank you very much
for coming out tonight.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.